hospitals all over the nation are
filling up with covet patients who all
have one thing in common nearly every
patient with coveted symptoms they take
to the hospital is unvaccinated this is
a pandemic of the unvaccinated
millions of americans who are eligible
for shots still choose not to get them
and fda approval of pfizer's vaccine
doesn't seem to have changed the rate of
vaccinations or people's views on
getting them
so let's take a look at who's not
getting vaccinated and why
[Music]
so
but why are so many people refusing to
get the shot
75 percent of adults refusing
vaccination are skeptical of both covid
and its vaccines
ninety percent of this group say they
are not worried about getting sick from
proven 19 and are less convinced the
vaccines work
36 of adults on the vaccine fence are
mostly worried about the side effects
and 31 fear the vaccines move through
clinical trials too quickly
22 percent of unvaccinated adults don't
think vaccines prevent dying from covert
19 with 19 saying the vaccines do
nothing to prevent serious illness
hospitalization or becoming infected if
exposed
[Music]